دكتور عبد الله كيف تضمن أن
أفغانستان
لن تكون ملاذا آمنا للإرهابيين
في المستقبل.
لا أعتقد أن هناك
ضمانا وهناك أيضا طالبان
فشلوا ووعدوا
بأنهم سيفصلون عن القاعدة في إرهابي آخر.
مجموعات
ليس لدينا الكثير من المؤشرات على ذلك ، لذلك
هذا هو
الخطر علينا وكذلك على المنطقة وخارجها
، قال تقرير استخباراتي
أمريكي إن الحكومة الأفغانية يمكن أن تسقط في غضون ستة
أشهر
بمجرد انسحاب القوات الأمريكية ، هل ترى في
يوم من الأيام قيام طالبان بإسقاط الحكومة الأفغانية.  الحكومة الأفغانية
لا
إن شاء الله قد يكون تفكيرهم أو
تفكيرهم
في أجزاء من حركة طالبان ولكن هذا
لن يحدث ،
فمن الواضح أنك مسؤول عن محادثات السلام
بين
الحكومة الأفغانية وطالبان ،
لقد قلت بنفسك إنهم
لم يحرزوا أي تقدم.
ما هو أحدث تقدم ضئيل للغاية
وتيرة بطيئة للغاية وانظر إلى مدى إلحاح
الوضع ،
انظر إلى ما يجري في
البلد والفرص التي نفوتها
نتيجة  استمرار الحرب ،
ما رأيك في العشرين عامًا الماضية
التي حققتها أطول
حرب أمريكية لأفغانستان كانت معظم أجزاء
أفغانستان تحت سيطرة طالبان.
كانت القاعدة تعمل بالقطعة التي كان أسامة بن لادن
يخطط لها في واشنطن وفي نيويورك من
أفغانستان
هذا الجزء بالطبع
لا تزال هناك بعض
التحديات التي تواجه وضع المرأة في أفغانستان ،
لذا فإن حرية التعبير
والوعي للناس
بحقوقهم مختلفة
تمامًا.
رسالتك إلى هؤلاء الأشخاص ،
هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين ربما كانوا
مستقبل هذا
البلد ، يمر شعبنا
بأوقات صعبة للغاية
دعمنا بها العالم
وسيستمرون في تقديم الدعم ،
لكننا وحدنا من يستطيع إنقاذ
أولئك الذين يؤمنون بالجيش.
تولي مسؤولية
استمرار معاناة الشعب الذي
يعاني  ولن
تتحقق أفكارهم